- This is considered the
most right wing government
in Israel's history,
led by Prime Minister Benjamin Netanyahu.
This is the National Security Minister.
He was once convicted
of incitement to racism
and belonging to a terrorist organization.
And this is the Finance Minister.
He's advocated for permanent
Israeli rule over the West Bank
without giving Palestinians
the right to vote.
Many of these politicians
are strongly in favor
of the judicial overhaul plan
that sparked massive protests
and created a rift with allies.
- They cannot continue down this road.
- Well, Netanyahu now says
he wants to seek compromise,
he needs to keep the
support of his coalition
in order to stay in power.
So here's how Netanyahu came
to be politically reliant
on religious and ultranationalist parties
and why the interests of his government
are now clashing with many of
Israel's citizens and allies.
Before we talk about
the judicial overhaul,
let's talk about how
Netanyahu came back into power
in the first place.
Just a few years ago,
it looked like his political
career might be over.
In 2019, he was indicted on
bribery and fraud charges,
which he denies.
And in 2021,
his rivals agreed to form a
new government to oust him.
But Netanyahu didn't back down.
(speaking foreign languages)
He fought the charges, and even
though he was still on trial
during the campaign, he
pulled off an election victory
by uniting right wing, ultranationalist,
and religiously conservative parties.
That opened the door for
people like Itamar Ben-Gvir,
leader of the Jewish Power Party,
to secure top government positions.
(speaking foreign language)
Politicians in Netanyahu's
government support
all kinds of divisive policies,
but one of their biggest priorities
is to overhaul the
country's judicial system
so that they as politicians can override
Supreme Court decisions
that they don't agree with.
So why is this judicial overhaul
such a big deal to them?
Unlike in the US and some
other Western countries,
Israel doesn't have a
written constitution.
Judges are picked by a
judicial selection committee,
not politicians,
and they base their decisions
on British common law,
evolving Israeli precedent,
and a series of basic laws.
Supporters of this system say it provides
checks and balances against parliament.
But for decades, Israel's right
wing has accused the court
of having a left wing bias.
For example, most Israelis are subject
to mandatory military service,
but many in Netanyahu's government
want Ultra-Orthodox Jews
to be exempt from it,
so that they can study
Jewish texts full-time.
But when Parliament passed a
law on that a few years ago,
the court struck it down
saying it was unconstitutional.
So fast forward to January,
when Netanyahu and his allies took power,
they put out proposals to
completely change the system
like giving lawmakers
power on the committee
that appoints judges, making
it easier for Parliament
to overrule Supreme Court decisions,
and making it harder for
judges to strike down
Parliament's Laws.
The proposals set off a wave of protests
with demonstrators saying the overhaul
would weaken Israel's checks and balances.
- This is emergency time
for the democracy of Israel.
- [Shelby] Crucially,
scores of Israeli reservists
said they would refuse to
serve if the reforms passed.
On the other side,
supporters of the proposals
also demonstrated,
demanding that the proposals move forward.
(speaking foreign language)
- And they were cheered on by
some in Netanyahu's cabinet,
who tweeted videos and thanked
them for their support.
With flights grounded,
schools shut and banks closed,
Netanyahu pressed pause
and his coalition agreed
to suspend some of the
more contentious issues
until after Passover.
(speaking foreign language)
But the showdown is far from over.
Some in Netanyahu's
Coalition are still vowing
to press ahead with the reforms.
At the same time, Netanyahu
is facing pressure
from Israeli citizens who
continue to demonstrate,
and the United States,
which is Israel's
largest security partner.
- Like many strong supporters
of Israel, I'm very concerned.
- [Shelby] Netanyahu responded,
saying Israel is a sovereign country
which makes its decisions
by the will of its people
and not based on pressures from abroad,
including from the best of friends.
Now, analysts say if
Netanyahu really wants
to reach a consensus,
he'll have to give
members of his coalition
something in return.
Already he has agreed to give Ben-Gvir,
the National Security
Minister, even more power,
by handing him control
of the National Guard,
a move that would put the Ultranationalist
in charge of handling protests.
(gentle music)